hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
a video Rachele party and live at the
Apollo this is a top reward tier request
from the most mysterious man at our
patreon page named Jay n Valente he's
sent us over quite a large selection of
what to choose from for the month well
with this one it's actually the lowest
viewed one out of them all we could have
gone with ones that have like million
views or whatever and I was like let's
go with the one that has the least views
because I'm most fascinated by female
comedians of them all let's get into it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Paris and yes I am here to bring
the noise
yes what you call in show business a
triple threat I do comedy and I do music
and I will cut you music so if you're a
fan of the NWA or Snoop Doggy dog then I
apologize I'll be about three minutes on
a train before so I'm going to sing this
song this is about the worst thing any
of us can ever encounter on a train
journey
[Music]
crystal clear if you listen carefully
I'm not even saying the word Hindu
[Laughter]
[Music]
Hemme do on a train when you wanna trade
[Music]
cowboy hats and his case neck tattoos
and bigger plates and voices like
[Music]
groping every passing male suspect
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
sounds like a dua
[Music]
[Music]
take your rain
we're not just three months ago my
friend tangu we got drunk and we pretty
much hijacked a plane
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
excited to be here with you it's so
exciting I'm very intimidating as well
and I do have something called impostor
syndrome it's where you feel unqualified
for most of the situation's you find
yourself in life is where it's maybe you
don't deserve to be where you are so
what I eat rare that I feel like I
deserve to be where I am I mean
sometimes you find yourself
you think yeah this is fair and this
happened to me a few months ago I was in
London - glittering Soho as I still call
it
I was outside a nightclub excuse me are
you Rachel Paris now what you have to
realize it that's my name and she said
this is amazing I just found on the
pavement
as well as situations that really like
flare up the last years I've got invited
really or not to go back to my old
school in LA to give an inspirational
speech to the graduating class the
[Laughter]
interesting interesting which I think we
can all agree makes me quite a high
level number three you want to do
something about that
number four you want to be best friends
with Tilda Swinton
[Laughter]
obviously
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
durable hey there's first time seeing
that woman yeah yeah quite charming very
charming quite the triple-threat indeed
comedians who can do songs and actually
do comedy simultaneously is one of the
most impressive skills to me ever you
guys ever go to a musical improv show
that's one of the most mind-blowing
experiences you'll ever go on right
there
yeah when those work man it is insane
when they don't work it's also and say
also enjoyable why I didn't say
therefore a wide variety of different
reasons I like her
what did she sing like Hindu I don't
know at the end I thought she
differentiated Hindu verses hen do and I
don't know if hen do is like a slang
term I'm not aware of hen do they've
Handerson and this often happens when we
googles her something while we're
recording the people look good you know
no it's huge yeah let's check the
comments if you're if you're British or
something and and we are missing
[Music]
this is like hen do like like like poop
from a hen or something is she just
describing the outside like a bird's
trapped under this drain or is she
fighting a belligerent Hindu man in a
cowboy hat with peace cake it might be
the latter what you're talking about and
then the punch line with the final song
would be Hindu I see this is this is
good comedy when you're really confused
so while editing this video I learned
that a Hindu is actually a British term
for a bachelorette party or really like
a bachelorette weekend of sorts so uh
this just makes a whole lot more sense
now she did is smart because she set it
up with going I'm not saying Hindu if
you listen carefully I'm not even saying
the word Hindu India wouldn't hate you
and so it's funny every time she's
saying it because it sounds like she's
saying India yeah yeah I wonder if she
knows this a certain amount of us are
gonna be like what is happening I've had
some pretty awful train experiences I
used to ride the subway from like 1518 I
would ride the subway I mean it was like
14 18 actually I ride the subway all the
time extra year I'll get you know will
and I remember one time a lot of crazies
on the train from all different usually
the common ethnicities were white black
or Latino LA tène oh that's the correct
way to pronounce it
Latino then one time there was a black
man black stop who came up to me and he
just there's always like random
conflicts on the train and one time a
black guy came up to me he's like yo I
heard what she said and he had one of
those things we had like one eye the
other eye was like a glass eye or
something he's like I heard she said I
had headphones I was like I'm sorry I'm
like a 15 year old kid
and he this guy's a grown man I'm like
I'm sorry he's like I heard you call me
and he said the n-word and then sure
enough everyone's ears around me popped
up oh well just like white people it was
it's everybody variety of ethnicity he
just kept saying to me that I heard you
call me what you want to start something
kept saying it I'm like I really didn't
say anything to you I got off on the
next stop which was not my stop but I
just had to get out of that awkward
situation as soon as possible
yeah and that's just an LA subway
station or a train can imagine how it
isn't like other parts of the world like
UK or New York we're riding the train is
a common way of transportation is not
underserved much much more daunting
experience but back to her Rachel
there's something about her comedy form
that's like I don't it's like this
mixture of slight edge elegant British
humour with some of that dry wit I feel
like a lot of variety of humor within
her but she's also very sharp in her and
her timing and the structure of her
dialogue that she's communicating to us
she was rather a fascinating performer
she's like someone I'd love to see on
the stage where her he ever probably
even trans looks better being there live
on a stage as opposed to watching like a
YouTube video of her at the Apollo
yeah but she's really correct I mean
like her form is really crisp and what's
interesting to me is I feel like a lot
of the musical comedians I've seen or
comedians who jump into music have sort
of a more out there or alternative act
and I thought that when she was up on
her feet telling jokes you know that was
very in the tradition of stand-up you
know it's yeah setups and punchlines and
whatnot and then you know she kind of
seamlessly transitions into the musical
bits which are a bit more fluid and
stuff like that so I thought was cool to
see because he liked a lot of comedians
will scoff at musical comedy in general
and she's clearly dead like it's not
even like a bo burnham thing where
everything is kind of on its ear and off
the walls and stuff what do you think
industrial piping close stay out of it
she's jumping up and doing like really
solid traditional stand-up and then
jumping right over there doing some kind
of difference so I appreciated the blend
she brought to that yeah yeah she was
great
mm-hmm I want to see more from where all
she's been this video December 7 2018 so
that old I gotta find more of this and a
bit about feminism was also very funny
feminism has been an ongoing topic in my
life since Captain Marvel and so hearing
this bit I was like ah humor nice to
hear humor about feminism for a change
and the chorus of cliques as people
frantically leave the video air
the fear of stomaching and new ideas hey
well thanks JN for this request buddy JN
is the kind of guy who will vanish they
pledged and eventually show up again out
of nowhere with a with a hole 8 what I
see throughout the week I'll do this
thing called stream of consciousness
journaling where I just write pages for
three straight pages or I'll set a timer
for 15 minutes and just keep writing
whatever random thoughts come to my mind
and JM Valente he is a guy who decides
to not do that through a journal he
decides to do that through my patreon
inboxes so half the time I don't know
what he's talking about it is bizarre
crazy stuff and then I'll find a couple
of sentences where I'm like okay I can
reply to that but then there's other
parts of them like oh yeah I probably
take like 20 to 30 minutes to respond to
J and on on patreon because about 15 to
20 of those minutes are not actual
typing it's me trying to decipher what
he's talking about that it's about five
minutes of me going I give up and then
five minutes of actually replying
so JM thank you for being who you are
and I don't want that to ever change if
if you ever start replying to me and
typing to me messages that like make
perfect sense
we're gonna have a major issue I want it
to be as complex as possible because
when you pass on a hundred years from
now because you're gonna live for a very
long time when you pass on 100 years
from now those those words are gonna be
things that people will try to make
sense of what you are you will be
perceived as a genius so keep it up
buddy let's start a whole new language a
whole new civilization
Valente ism Valente which means brave
and valiant oh yeah I mean Jan
demonstrates those qualities
especially when airing out ideas
unfiltered yeah I think he realizes he's
talking to me guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and we'll catch you
guys later